Gentlemen, now
gentlemen,
more gentlemen.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
in the chapters of bathing
in the book of purification
of Elwajis.
We discussed yesterday morning
the instances in which
the instances or occasions
that make
bathing obligatory binding upon a
person. Now some of these occasions
necessitate bathing in order that
another act of war should be accepted.
And some of them necessitate bathing
because of the time or occasion.
However,
bathing in its most simple terms
really has only two pillars. We've
mentioned this many times before
that
every act of worship
has pillars. Every act of worship has
pillars and bathing is no different. It
has pillars
and its pillars are two.
Now before I mention this, I want to
make something very clear. Where did
this
issue of conditions, pillars,
obligations, sunen where did these
categories come from? Well, originally
you'll find their essence and the basis
and foundations for these
categories in the Quran and Sunnah.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
left instances throughout his sunnah
that the scholars would understand and
discern.
However,
learning and teaching has become very
different than it was many many years
ago.
The way that the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam would teach the
companions. The way that the companions
would teach each other, teach their
families, teach the next generation
is they would see or hear something from
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam and
they would do it exactly as they saw it.
The general masses this is their
prerogative and that has not changed.
the scholars in order to teach
these very expansive acts of worship
and to make these acts of worship
digestible to other students. Especially
when knowledge became very abstract.
They
divided things into these categories to
make these things digestible.
However, these categories they are not
the basis of worship.
The basis of worship is
the basis of worship is whatever the
messenger gives you, take it and
whatever he denies you or prohibits you,
steer clear of it. The basis of worship
is
we hear and we obey.
It is not. Is this obligatory? Do I have
to? if I don't do this, will I be
dumped into hell or can I get away with
not doing it? This is not the basis of
worship. This is an important
distinction
because
some things are a sunnah.
meaning that the act of worship itself
does not
become invalid if this thing is failed
to be done. However,
if it were left off, it would be
unanimously considered a bad thing. I'll
give you an example. Let's say you came
to today
and I began the salah Allahbar
and then you you didn't hear me recite
you didn't hear me and then Allahbar and
I go into
then I stand up and complete salah and
then the second you don't hear me recite
I recite to myself
would our prayer be valid valid or
invalid.
The only thing I didn't do was recite
out loud.
I recited to myself and you guys
followed me. Would our prayer be valid
or invalid?
Be valid
because raising the voice in recitation
and
is it a sunnah or an obligation of
salah? It's a sunnah. It's not an
obligation.
What about if I only recited fat only
only
and went straight to no other surah?
Would our salah be valid or invalid?
Valid. Would we not all agree that
that's unacceptable?
We would, right? What makes it different
if we do it together or if we do it
alone? This is not a basis of adherence
or lack of adherence. This is just a
categorization so as to make it
digestible in teaching.
That's the only purpose of these these
things.
So the pillars of
bathing are two pillars.
The first pillar is intention.
I have to have the intention of bathing.
The second pillar
is
is to entirely
wash all of the body.
All of it.
all of the skin, all of the body and all
of that which has the ruling of being
the outer part of the body.
My the mouth, the nose is not part of
the outer body. However, it has the
ruling
of being part of the outer body.
Correct? If a person is fasting
and they taste something,
they put the water in their mouth for
woo and spit it out. Did they break
their fast? No. Why not? When did they
break their fast? Once once they drink
it, right? Once it goes down the throat.
So the mouth and the nose
le in the legislation of Islam are
considered part of the outside of the
body.
And so when a person makes
they have to have the intention of
and second of all they have to
completely
run the water over all of the body
including the mouth and nose.
Now when we say intention
does that mean I have to say it out
loud? No. Intention takes place in the
heart. There's no such thing as an
intention that is spoken. I may inform
of my intention, but me saying something
that is not an intention.
Now, why do we say this? Well, let's say
for instance,
a person is in a state of janaba.
They go to sleep. They sleep through the
night. They wake up the next morning to
go to work.
A lot of people, most people, and I
certainly hope all people in Arizona in
this heat,
I would hope bathe before they go out,
right? We take a shower to start our
day. the luxuries of first world
21st century technology.
Imagine we live kings.
meat whenever you want. Eat whenever you
want. If we have a meal without high
quality meat in it, we consider that a
snack. That's not even a meal. That's
how well we're living.
But part of that is water on tap. So, we
take a shower every day. A person takes
his morning routine shower. He forgot
that he was in Janine,
but he took the shower completely.
Then he gets dressed and he goes out the
door.
Then he remembers that he was in janaba.
Did he take makeul or not?
He did not makeul. He is still in
janaba.
Why? Because he did not have the
intention of
He did the action, but he didn't have
the intention.
And we've mentioned this before. This is
a rare instance, but it is plausible and
it is possible and is actually more
common than you would think.
Merely taking a a bath or bathing is not
enough. You have to have two pillars.
The first pillar
intention.
The second pillar
that water washes over the entirety of
the body including the mouth and the
nose.
Now this also
brings in other issues that is
usually more pertinent to females in
this era such as eyelashes and weaves
and wigs and
nail polish and so forth. We will
discuss these issues tomorrow inshallah.
for
[Silence]
being a Muhammad.